[Music]
in coming soon news submitted by it's
already March how did that have it to
your already I hope you like time is
just passing without me even knowing
that it's going no we're too much on
autopilot hmm flaming hot cheetos movie
is coming to theaters shut the [ __ ] up
wow that sounds like something I never
want to see you never it sounds like
something made by the people who made
like the emoji movie oh yeah like that
you know is it you guys but I was
feeling the opposite I was like that's
[ __ ] doubt you even got a bag of
flaming hot cheetos right there you liar
I stole from she'll be super down if all
the popcorn is flamin hot popcorn if
they do that like for the movie theater
there's some sort of theme because I
can't tied up with the eyeballs I got I
don't really get what the thing is but
if they could tie it all together I'd be
down with it I will say this though
flaming hot did a very good job on
creating that lower fat version the
baked version other thing it's actually
not bad the biggest lay my heart still
it doesn't taste as good as the old nan
GOG however yeah I don't eat it then I
go okay I go oh different yeah it's it's
own breathe have you guys read the sir
about how hot cheetos started that's why
they're making the movie Oh dope
everything yeah
good all the movies called flamin hot so
it's a biopic yes yeah so it's about the
the person who invented hot cheetos
flamin hot cheetos which his name is
richard month anya's and so he worked at
a new it he worked as a janitor it would
be a Mexican and then read only plant
and since 1976 so back then there was
some something happen with the Machine I
know what happened
cheese it up what he got drunk as most
Mexicans do do tap a teal in the Machine
accidentally [ __ ] what
mafia
don't you okay that's how happened dude
that's innovative we're passionate
innovative well I'm not knocking it
whoever a wand Valdez is I really do
appreciate it's so funny that I
mentioned that Mexican people get drunk
at work when that's not true and I had a
Chinese handyman come to my place and he
opened up a beer right in front of me
what yeah he was like he supposed to fix
my garage nice cars
okay all Chinese construction workers
they all drink on the job
you know the [ __ ] normal like one I
had a one summer job where my mom asked
me if I wanted to just make extra money
and shedder but contractor homie I'm not
sure I'll help you out and then for a
lunch time I'm gonna go pick up lunch
she goes no just give me a pack of beer
give me a pack of beers okay all right
all right bro all right dude here's the
[ __ ] the bowling ball thing the
[ __ ] like a nail gun in shades [ __ ]
you just drinking beer okay I was
supposed to do something but I did you
guys see that video of that kid
he had his head on the [ __ ] dartboard
yes was so funny
he has his head on a dartboard the guy
supposed to throw the dart right and he
goes go it's in your it's in your head
he goes huh it's in your it was just so
sudden
yeah well going back to how he made hot
cheetos though it was so the machine
that's supposed to cheese it up and then
it breaking down so he took some of the
cheetos that weren't cheesed up and we
took him home he got this idea from the
court that I looked there oh man or the
corn man comes and he puts he puts like
cheese
what else we spices and all that stuff
the cookie had cheese and the mayonnaise
yeah yeah lime on top no my mouth was
getting watery
okay decided to like just mix up spices
you put chili on the Cheetos that
weren't cheesed up and then he created
it and he also designed like the bag and
everything cuz the CEO frito-lay he was
able to talk to him because he the CEO
had sent out a video message to all the
employees telling them like you know
treat this company as if you're the
owner if you ever have any ideas feel
free to come up and like let us know
what ideas you have so that motivated
him too and then they took his idea
kicked his ass out no so what is he like
the is he the CEO of flaming hots no no
he's a see oh he cannot see you he leads
multicultural sales and community
promotions that's amazing hos North
American division that's amazing from
janitor to manager yeah because like he
dropped out of school cuz it was really
hard for him to learn English after he
migrated from Mexico as a kid and so
once he was able to get that meeting
with the CEO he spent the CEO gave him
two weeks to prepare presentation and so
you went to the life that was bad he
copied a marque a marketing strategy
from a book in the library and so I key
use that to present his idea and they
just loved it and so that's been like
the number one selling I don't think
they have so I believe it when I was a
kid I used to go to the flea market and
at the flea market in the morning there
is these bags of like pinwheel crackers
oh yeah and then you throw a bunch of
salt lime and Peppa teal and you shake
that [ __ ] up but I didn't know that [ __ ]
Randeep flamin hot cheetos come out let
me a wagon wheel it's in a black plastic
bag Mexico
yeah I don't even know that [ __ ] was
Mexican dude I had to [ __ ] my whole life
it was so bomb Tapatio stuff isn't label
and I love the way it like pops in your
mouth yes it seems like it touches your
tongue you with yup
let me you guys want to build that wall
flamin hot cheetos come on the 90s it
was a minute ago yeah cuz I don't
remember them existing when I was a kid
and it came out of nowhere like like it
was like a [ __ ] virus like all of a
sudden BAM
now everybody was eating yeah everyone
loved this like a super millionaire now
yeah I mean living a good life yeah
those flamin hot cheetos with nachos
cheese sauce that sounds delicious
though they had that oh they had that at
our school so they were served nachos
right but on the side the students made
their own [ __ ] where they sold 25 cents
for the cheese sauce and then you just
buy a bag of hot cheetos and they put it
in there and they just did I would say
like that 92 by the way with hot 92 okay
that makes sense I remember I used to
get like limes and lemons and squeeze it
in there and then wrap the bag up and
shake it like crazy and then I'll eat it
like no they came out with the lime
flavor yeah do that with with regular
Fritos - you just put the [ __ ]
Tapatio and the lima shake you know the
Lay's you put the top at the limit how
do you say Tapatio damn I love Mikey I
like Tapatio better than Cholula yeah it
took it took it took a bit of a switch I
like Tabasco smoked I originally like
Cholula then I switched the Tapatio
because has more of a lime flavor I like
both this is so good I want a [ __ ]
burrito I'm not a fries you guys know
that crunchy Cheetos was invented in
1948
oh yeah after I started eating crunchy I
don't never went back to puppy the
cheeto the hot flaming question was a
pretty bad bottle
your eyes are my favorite though I like
you though friends too
you know I'll say this though cheeto
puffs are dangerous because they
disintegrate so you just go at it for
days I like it when I get stuck on the
roof of my mouth yeah why don't eat
those I wish they would have them
involved though I don't like this good
cheese balls I know but I will they have
hot cheeto balls oh they should make
that that have a they don't think that
one is in the shape of [ __ ] like dried
[ __ ]
yeah maybe that's when they got the
shape from from his - hola master
we took about a baby so healthy it's so
hard to you know food is so meaty bit
eating a healthy pie three days I may be
healthy for now for a week and a half
I've lost seven pounds oh good job what
are you doing good job dude
so I actually have a dietician now that
actually has worked with me for the
first week that's time or it just kind
of gave me better eating habits in terms
of night not counting macros macros
right now are very stressful for me so
so how do you how do you count your
calories so right now is the first week
I don't count my colors so it's just I
took out so whatever I'm eating right
now like I can eat whatever I want but
it's portion control and on top of that
it's just like if I make the food is
always healthier you know yeah so you
know lean proteins a lot more fiber so
things that are a lot more fibrous and
things that I eat it also keeps me over
full fiber is bad yeah and I haven't
drank yet and it's fine I don't actually
drink a lot of water so because I've
been drinking more water
I should stay full a lot longer ya
helped out a [ __ ] lot also helped
that my skin and acne and everything up
yeah mostly little drink another one
like once we clear yeah and it's in your
stressed out a lot of the times because
you're dehydrated but you don't know
that
Jessica drinks a lot of water that day
she got me into water like it's a sport
water that's that she put me on food
guys
so much is crazy I think once a week in
this amber hard amber oh [ __ ] [ __ ] or
die that's called I think you're pissing
blood you are it's hard amber because
that like [ __ ] fiber it's hard amber
by the way it comes out like a gel like
a [ __ ] school make this a habit I
want you to do this Jean it's like three
seconds for you to get to the water I
want you to get a bottle of water or
glass of water and put it next to your
best time when you go to sleep so every
time you wake up as soon as you wake up
you pound that whole I do that yeah you
build a habit you build a habit to
drinking more more water go good job job
looked like somebody was raping you as
you were drinking that water that's my
monthly bottle of water an hour you're
not gonna thank god yeah you're supposed
to be PP once an hour I think you like
once in the morning in the afternoon and
before bed that's bad yeah you only pick
three times
you should be peeing once an hour it's
so bad oh I was good for a while when we
got those jaqen hydro flasks like those
[ __ ] on here yeah but like it's pretty
cool though because you was interesting
about a dietician like even if you know
what's healthy
just talking to somebody about it that's
more knowledgeable than you actually
helps you keep on track so I kind of
understand like what the dietitian is
for because a lot of people now that
because information is so accessible
just because you know it doesn't mean
you're gonna apply it yeah so if they
give you like a set regimen and you know
what you're doing so this week I
actually do have macros and they're
pretty doable you know I mean and also
too I've been walking like two miles a
day
to where I have an inguinal hernia so
it's basically you're you're kind of
Guido's hernias basically like your your
intestine pokes out of your abdominal
muscles and so yeah no I'm too fat so
you can't you can't see but basically I
had that so I have to use walking
instead of working out but yeah how did
you get these knees to her actually from
coffee so yeah really sorry yeah well
going back to Richard here the janitor
that created hot cheetos I thought it
was really awesome what he said so
there's a quote from him he said the
antidote to fear is hunger when you have
hunger for a job position knowledge
knowledge or a new house you go and get
it and fear will never get ahold of you
I love that why did I did I think his
quote was gonna be killer be killed si
[Laughter]
it's really awesome too because like you
know he's been successful in stuff he
gets back to the Latino community and he
gives like scholarship [ __ ] let me kill
this a billionaire they're like so
inspirational to life
that's not cry later with the [ __ ]
epic aspect profile shot he looks like
the uncle that everyday that's tight oh
I'm so looking forward to the movie
flaming huts I want to watch it I want
to see that too actually
[Music]